[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning
here at augusta national patrons lucky
enough to take in the final two rounds
of the masters in person get to feast
their eyes on the club's natural beauty
from the georgia pines to the vibrant
azaleas along with some of golf's best
players and when it comes to actual
feasting the food choices are simple yet
legendary the pimento cheese and egg
salad sandwiches still just a dollar
fifty a piece
and it turns out away from augusta
national culinary traditions are also a
part of masters week today on a special
edition of the dish luigi's an annual
stop for patrons and golfers alike rich
in family and flavor
[Music]
step into luigi's restaurant in augusta
georgia and you're transported back in
time we have old family pictures
golfers arnold palmer
jack nicholas bear man you have
everybody
penelope ballast stewart is the fourth
generation in her family to run the
restaurant now augusta's oldest one of
the things that we're known for these
jew boxes
that's amore dean martin some elvis
frank sinatra
is it really a billy holiday it is a
quarter
you get a deal if you go up to the main
box up front you get three plays for two
quarters while the music may set the
tone it's luigi's food which has made it
a fixture in town since its doors opened
in 1949 but don't let the italian name
fool you the cuisine or italian italian
i like that that's right part greek part
italian a combo that dates back to
penelope's great grandfather nick ballas
who immigrated to the u.s from greece he
didn't open a greek restaurant he opened
a luigi reason for that so greek food
was definitely
they would have thought it was very
foreign back then yeah so through the
years he added some greek items onto the
menu and even the meat sauce and the
sauces have a bit of a greek flair that
flare adding to traditional italian
favorites like the chicken parmesan and
toasted ravioli
and of course greek offerings like the
greek salad with homemade dressing
oh my gosh that's delicious
and the restaurant's signature dish
greek chicken
falls off it does because it's cooked in
the pizza oven that is the secret
ingredient with the chicken it's such a
high heat that it locks in all of the
juice and really gives it that crisp on
the outside for a little kick there's
the homemade sausage in luigi's made to
order lasagna
[Music]
oh yeah
oh that's great
oh my god i love spicy it is the sausage
is amazing that was my great
grandfather's recipe that sausage also a
part of the ultimate gratalian offering
so the greek combination pizza
has a pepperoni the italian sausage
tomatoes feta cheese bell peppers onions
mushrooms turns out penelope's great
grandfather was the first to bring any
kind of pizza to augusta putting it on
the menu in 1949 as pizza pie
customers because it was new to the area
had no clue what it was so they would
order it for dessert and then at the end
they would order a pizza and they're
waiting for their surprise that it was
what it was
as for actual dessert the house favorite
is simple a greek sundae of ice cream
and homemade baklava we call it pennies
delight
because my grandmother penny
is the one who created it thank you
penny i know
penelope's grandmother who she's named
after was famous for that baklava one of
the family recipes passed down from one
generation to the next so the recipes
have not changed for the most part every
generation maybe has tweaked something
here or there but for the most part
everything is the same hand it down
verbally literally in a little black
book a different little black book than
what people might think right right it's
the same recipes penelope grew up eating
at luigi's which doubled as the family
gathering spot with her grandparents
then parents running the restaurant when
did you know that this was what you
wanted to do i always wanted to do it
i've just always loved every aspect of
the business it's all i ever wanted to
do part of the business at luigi's an
appreciation of golf which started with
her grandfather chuck he loved the
masters tournament and back in the early
days of the tournament when it wasn't
you know it was anybody could buy a
badge
he would buy tickets and hand them out
to help promote and just customers yes
and he was there used to be a master's
parade and he was the chairman for the
parade masters week the busiest of the
year for luigi's back when penelope's
grandfather ran things and now people
used to walk up and ask my grandfather
how long is the weight and he would say
don't ask just get we serve cocktails
while people wait to just get a drink
and enjoy the company out here
and you get a seat when you get a seat
her grandfather was also the one who
started this collection of masters
badges which her father has proudly
added to these date back to 63. wow do
you know how much this is worth i don't
i don't we get you know people come in
and want to make offers on it every year
while penelope says it's not for sale
there's one thing her family treasures
even more when it comes to the masters
every year you see the same faces come
through sometimes some new faces but the
same customers come in from all
different parts of the world
and it's not just the masters patrons
ben crenshaw comes and sees us every
year he's one of our favorites we have a
soft spot for a gentleman you lit up
right there
because he's such a genuine person
and his wife julie and their girls let
me see they all come in
the nicholas family would eat with us
every year um the pilots would come eat
with us and take food back to the air
bear
so i mean it's just lots of traditions
just like passing on the family business
i would come and work you know side by
side with my dad just during the
transition
as he did with his father and his father
did with his father and you were telling
me about your daughter she just has the
knack it's just in her blood and we have
such a big family i can't imagine that
there won't be that love among
someone in the fifth generation so our
goal is definitely to keep it moving
forward luigi's going on
many generations that's our that's our
plan hit the century mark that's it
and we could not ship luigi's back to
you guys but i wanted you to be able to
eat and i wanted to keep with tradition
so like i have the pimento cheese and
egg salad sandwiches here i know you
have them back in studio
i've been enjoying them every day along
with a crow's nest so i hope you guys
enjoy just a little taste of the masters
that i was able to send you
you know when i lived in columbia south
carolina pimento cheese was my go-to
sandwich because you know i didn't eat
meat
this was it and you got to put potato
chips in it and how much of these cost
there dollar fifty dollar wow that's it
so good isn't that great classic good
stuff